[Music]
in our democracy in the real world and
half rules freedom of speech doesn't
mean absolute freedom to say anything
you want at any point in time everywhere
it comes with a responsibility it goes
the freedom of one goes to where it
infringes on the freedom of another you
know the freedom from being demonized
the freedom from being abused and that's
why freedom of speech works in the real
world democracy because we have those
protections built in and Zola's
protection we have decided because we
have voted politicians in place through
generations that build up the democracy
we live in today and it's just those
same rules we shall make to apply on the
internet because what you're saying
ends up in what we're seeing now which
is anarchy and anarchy is not freedom
for everybody anarchy is always rule of
the bully and the bully is the mock
culture that we see and if you have as I
have an announcement have been subject
to online bullying hacking undermining
identity theft you have no doubt that
you rather have a garment regulate than
the mobs and you raise an interesting
point here please the mob that's a well
I think it's the mall I think the crisis
also how much of this new so we've we've
touched on this points that we have
existing laws that govern these
questions in the so-called analog world
does the digital world as the Internet
world require new laws or did the analog
laws work so I'm about to punt this over
to you Nigel okay well we do have you
know we do have and of course we do need
laws that govern how we behave in the
real world and in the digital world and
we have laws and these laws are equally
applicable in the digital world as in
the real world if somebody libels you
you have recourse through you know the
civil courts if somebody throws racist
slurs at you there are laws that
actually prevent that from happening the
problem of course is you know as much as
anything
one of practicality how in practice do
we enforce these in a situation where
there is so much of this going on all
the time
day in and day out you know it's not a
job for the police they're not resourced
nor configured to do a job like this the
police that we have are that to police
us as people they're not there to police
ideas or you know or people thinking the
technology majors yes we are now
starting to put pressure on them to do
more to improve the quality of online
discourse I mean you know they it's it's
been a depressing experience watching
the denial obfuscation and general
reluctance to accept responsibility for
the content from which they so
manifestly benefit but we are now
starting to get our arms starting to get
our arms around this problem and
certainly in the United States and I
think this does matter because at the
end of the day the USA is still where
the weather is made online politicians
are starting to get to grips with this
and we should be encouraging them to do
so and the e u.s. is at the forefront
and which is why one of the things they
hate about the EU because of these
freedom warriors thinking they're you
but but can I make a really important
point which I've only been thinking
about in the last three or four days in
there's a new play that has been written
by a young playwright at the Soho
Theatre and it's based on extensive
interviews with the community around
those three girls in the East End who
went off to join Isis it's a fantastic
play and it's called does my bum look
big in this it's a great title too and
one of the things that you there were
lots of parents there the night I went
to see it and the number of them said if
only we could do speakers what happened
was these girls were like teenagers be
discontent whatever it was what they saw
online
that got them into this place where they
ended up and I think two of them have
died so when we talk about the Internet
we need to remember some of the really
awful things that are coming out of this
uncontrollables out of this
uncontrollable space for more debates
talks and interviews subscribe today to
the Institute of Arts and ideas at IAI
TV
you